hello everyone and welcome to part 14
of my resident evil village let's play
where i'm pretty sure this is actually
the end of the game we're about to go
meet mother miranda who as it turns out
was
imitating my wife mia which is still
quite confusing to me because i'm not
sure
if my child is the illegitimate child of
mother miranda or
is it still mia's child and also where
is mia then
um because if it's mother miranda's
child
[ __ ] her really i don't care uh we
didn't fight heisenberg we just fought
fan man and i still love heisenberg he's
a cool mech now who i'm still
hoping i'm holding out hope that maybe
he'll team up with us uh i don't want to
fight him i think he's
one of the coolest things i've ever seen
in my life
uh you told me to get in the elevator
and i'm in it now
um did you want me to you want me to
take this thing
is that what you're telling me
you do want me to take this thing
this is the dumbest [ __ ] i've ever seen
and i'm here for it
so i think chris built this composite
huh time to fight fire with
fire of course yeah it's metapolymer
composite
i'm coming rose okay
first let me just get this elevator
don't mind me oh
oh cool
okay am i just gonna go straight up to a
boss fight
i'm excited see what happens
truly it can't take that long okay rt's
machine gun auntie's fire cannon
elvis god
oh my
it is gonna be that game okay
let's bloody do it then
somehow oh right sorry yeah that makes
sense actually
you wanted to teach me how to use that
okay you're like a goddamn cockroach i
don't want to fight you eisenberg
i'm really sorry dude i this is all
ethan i want you to know that i didn't
have anything to do with any of this
[ __ ]
this is all ethan
and i think we can both agree that he's
a giant turd burger
i'm supposed to break those maybe rather
than blocking them
even he's like biomass
i feel like you could just crush me
much easier than any of this
thank you also i'm sorry again you know
it's funny though when we walked out
through this field i was like this is
too much space there's no way
and as it turns out i was right show me
what you've got
i missed
[Music]
i dude i am feeling what you're putting
out
i maintain that i think you're really
[ __ ] cool and you don't need to flex
on me this hard
i'm already team heisenberg
she really has done a [ __ ] number on
everyone
in this town
fine with it i don't even know that
she's mine
well i blocked that one no
i'm not no i feel like i should be
he's much bigger than me
hi i
got that shoulder
you say that but
he's still alive which again i'm full
i don't want to be doing this to you i
was very on board with the propaganda
[Music]
the auntie miranda she she seems like
she's really toxic
all i'm saying is oh my oh oh
is that we should explore canceling
maybe
a twitter takedown is the right fit
maybe if we damage her reputation enough
[Music]
well okay now i'm a bit less confident
that i was
now i'm oh god oh my god
now i'm a bit more i'm sort of concerned
you think shotgun ammo is going to help
me
i think shotgun ammo is going to be the
right call
we'll just take him out with shotgun
emma is that kind of where we're at
um let's equip this man
because i don't think we'll be using the
handgun anytime soon
that's a flashbang that's not gonna help
no it did
okay
[Music]
it does sort of feel hopeless because
you don't have any big
orange spots on you
oh oh my i know i'm in the middle of
battle right now but if you could just
give me a second to clean this [ __ ]
up
oh that would be great thank you
[Applause]
didn't even mean to hit that i could use
the magnum but i don't know where i'm
supposed to be hitting it
[ __ ] help
thanks king if you have weak spots i'm
just not seeing them
anytime where are they you know
is it does he is he does just hold him
oh my god okay okay
yeah okay that's all it's a lot that
you're throwing at me here but i'm
apparently invincible somehow invincible
trying not to dude i'm just wasting
[ __ ] shotgun ammo out here
are you killable you know that's the
[ __ ] question
you are okay okay
so maybe i should equip magnum
i think i probably should just to do the
damage
but we'll still do this first
[Music]
wow i never thought i'd see this it's a
lot of ammo
it's so much out
okay i'm just gonna just gonna do that
to you
just gonna run to the side again
excuse me just hang on just a second if
you wouldn't mind sir
i'm gonna do that okay let's see
i agree i strongly [ __ ] agree
[Music]
oh my god ethan you are getting
[Music]
listen heisenberg i'm super sorry
you're the coolest man i've ever seen in
my entire [ __ ] life
i do not buy that ethan winters could
beat you in a fight in a million years
oh god
but i also um
that's what i call chris alpha
you can't see that it's surname is chad
find miranda and get rose back
not without me it's too dangerous
ethan
couldn't that be miranda pretending to
be rose
mia our child
she's so important isn't she no we don't
like this it's everything to me
and mine to me on the train
you've lost your lead what are you going
to do
couldn't i just shoot her in the face
but i'm saving rose
yeah you'd never know do you
even when i took mia's place in your
home
poor ethan it's pretty [ __ ] up where's
rose
we don't even have that pistol ethan
enough
cosplay the [ __ ] out of her power she's
cool looking
rose is her successor no
rose is evelyn's true complete form
she will grow to fully control the
masses
and i must
ethan again i'm just not sure
those are the right words to use here
rose will be saved
the mega my seat catalogs all of us
however she will be reborn as my
daughter she's my child not yours
after all we've been through i don't
know that you should be that afraid of
crows why did rose come
to be first
yeah and you are truly a special case
my one friend was hero as well oh no
your worth as a lab rat has run out
miranda you coward come on and face me
don't your death will come quick
you will join the mega man
i feel like our noses are sort of
similar i will make sure to sample your
blood
for later one stone breaks
the ceremony will be complete and i will
become
her true mother you could have just
offered eight million dollars and we
could have signed some papers dude i
don't know that you needed to do all
this
offer me some cash and i would have
handed the adoption papers right over
did she take my heart i've waited
so long but dreams
really can come true
i don't know that ethan's gonna recover
from this one
what
captain i've confirmed the death of oh
my
what i wasn't able to retrieve the body
honestly
yesterday we took down the transformed
miranda
but we didn't kill her who knew she
could fake being a corpse
since miranda could have infected ethan
i forcefully took him
and rose with us
but the vehicle they were riding in was
attacked
when i got to the wreck ethan and rose
were gone
the last time i was able to contact
ethan
i heard miranda's voice yeah she stole
my heart she murdered him
she yeah she did and she is not gonna
get away with it
i think if i would over dramatize
ethan winters's death here god damn it
when does it end
what's that sir the mission
all of it three years trying to put this
thing in the ground
three years too long sometimes it do be
like that
we'll get her captain
cool i'm all right with this
ethan really should have teamed up with
heisenberg everything would have been
okay you know
he had it [ __ ] coming they say hey
got here already they didn't waste any
time
mission adjustment no it doesn't change
anything
terminate miranda and rescue rose
that's the mission and failure's not an
option let's have some fun people
like old times move out roger
thing to say all right i'm hoping this
is good i want to know what the hell
bsaa is doing here
find out what you can roger that i'm on
it
in a while since we fought together
captain
when was it last excuse me [ __ ]
i had i had magnum ammo i blamed the
internet for this okay
i was using magnum ammo appropriately
and then i got comments that were like
oh my god stop using magnum ammo
and so then i just didn't use it ever
damn it the desert all right
doing nothing but recon's gotten me out
of shape but thanks to your recon we
know miranda's plan
couldn't quite believe it when i heard
you turn yourself in the mia though
taking five shots to the head's nothing
to sneeze at either it's true
spooky bloody spooky
this is gonna be an assault rifle seems
like it
oh my
the alpha
yes hey they've gone too far
miranda controls the tree
how are you planning on reaching the
objective first we're going to have to
take that thing out
boss let's get to work it feels like i'm
playing medal of honor
watch for hostile buyer weapons roger
made contact with a group of hostile
weapons
i'm not sure how much weapon how much
how much damage this weapon does
seems like i'm gonna be pretty safe and
i should treat this like an action game
here
hang on again do i have a knife i hope
that he would
try to arrow me
but he's just got a knife himself
and also i'm assuming they're not
dropping anything no it's fine i need to
calm the [ __ ] down
don't get caught okay what do we what do
we what do we got
this all checks out what is this thing
it's like a pattern okay
i'm just i'm i can't even open the map i
need to [ __ ] chill out
it's okay it's the end of the game just
shoot people
you probably don't need to worry about
anything they gave you a lot of ammo uh
it's a tree
[Applause]
it is pretty gross oh all right frame
rate
i love that hey boss it's me maybe
releasing infections
keep it the two of you speaking at once
could you guys roger give me a second
tundra here
leaving some supplies in one of the
houses captain help yourself
this is a cool sequence
i also i'm i'm narratively i need to
back up
i'm narratively pretty satisfied so far
okay yeah
like i feel like ethan dying makes sense
nobody liked him it didn't make sense
that he even lived that long
hang on hang on now is my time i don't
care if i die right now to get this
[ __ ] achievement
try me try me try me try me do it do it
do it do it do it
i'm going to need to be the bosses oh
[ __ ] come on
i'm only looking at the guy who's really
far away from me okay let's deal with
these guys first
and then take this dude out
he's gonna come a little bit closer
there's his head oh hang on now i need
to take the knife out
we would have been perfect try me come
on do it
please please make it fast
all right give me a second i'm just
trying to get a [ __ ] achievement dude
just everybody calm down
oh i didn't even mean to throw that
grenade that was absolutely an accident
but i think maybe it hurt somebody so
we'll take it okay i'm too slow anyway
[ __ ] i should just reload and save to do
this probably
but i want it now
one more one more one more he hits on
the third one
keep [ __ ] missing i'll do it at a
later date so nobody has to watch me do
it
i'm very sorry i'm just committed
uh we prepare the other weapons so it's
not even gonna bother
i know i know i know
it's probably easier when you're closer
to them as well
yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe throw another
grenade there are a lot of them
[Applause]
okay
let's keep going
are they going to infinitely spawn is
that why you said keep moving
maybe they will
i was literally just reading the text
while shooting that this is a weird
crosshair though anyway
um okay let's keep going i've reached
the target location
damn this is big all right lobo marking
the target
roger that boss it's i mean it's the
whole thing is it not
it takes a minute to target the point
try and keep the laser on it as long as
you can
[Applause]
okay i thought that maybe it would
trigger in time
but it did not and everybody's died
please just give me
hey hey hey i'm excuse you all right i'm
just trying to throw my [ __ ] grenade
uh target locator it's the bottom one
all right blow everybody up first though
give me a
there second be something stimulating
they're probably still behind me
[Applause]
hold your horses i'm reloading
okay yeah it's fine i don't think i've
intended to kill them all
um
get back up a little bit oh is there
ammo here maybe i am supposed to kill
everybody
it just seems like a bit many
barrel there
you know where to point king go for it
no no
all right i'm in a bit of a corner here
mate
i would love both of you to die but
we're just gonna run ahead
well now
[Applause]
maybe grenade oh no i don't have any
grenades
hmm what's this
oh
it is nice to have an assault rifle give
it that much okay
target located because they will
infinitely
hurry up [ __ ] doing my [ __ ] best out
here okay
i can't
oh he got me
i think i use all the explosive barrels
too unless there's like another part
somewhere that i can probably
back up to um all right
for you we're just gonna take you out
right quick youtube
just play the laser on the target dude i
am [ __ ] trying but it takes you a
really long time
this is not super efficient
take that good mega mice must be below
it is yeah it's super [ __ ] up down
there oh it's the graveyard
oh i was like totally disorientated um
okay
just keep i found a way down swimming
i'm going in the rest of you stay back
captain i compared the mold in the
village with a sample from the bakers
mr bloody same
the stuff originated here how'd they get
it there
now i know how they got it there it's
resident evil
we know we know okay
um anything else for me here me mateys
okay now we're fine
anything okay
gonna be more like oh camera more likens
down here
that's a large weapon you have my good
sir
i'm just going to use this really and we
could equip whatever this that's flash
okay
target locator is probably not going to
work down here yeah i'll just
and grenade you
it's probably an invincible state to
presently
okay what is it about these trees that
keep making
the mega mices huh wolverines
you always have better aim than i think
you do
alright there you go no miss that one
great really love it
oh
this is like taking out the um what are
they called
the blind creatures oh that's right
there
i would like to get a better look at
this gentleman
he too is large and cute good
i'll signal with someone time
all right reloading now just a minute no
it takes about 10 [ __ ] minutes in the
heat of combat
jesus hey big guy hello yes hello big
jumpy boy
you are large and you are jumpy
not a fan of those tendrils it looks
like he has worms
it's not just it's just not a ton of
room for me to move in here buddy
okay yeah okay you're gonna jump back up
or like what's the plan here mate
this isn't gonna work it's not gonna
work at all no
no way
could you jump back up so i could just
oh come on
all right you are reloading
okay one more
you are a big boy and i respect you
and i'm very sorry it's come to this i'm
doing my job
you're doing yours you have a cooler
weapon than me i have
basically like a satellite rig in the
sky
you've got some kind of like spike
hammer
and i honestly am jealous and i think
all my friends are probably jealous and
maybe that's a big part of like why we
have to do this to you
jealousy is a drug
disease is what i meant in the next
round
oh my god okay
the next round is going to be the last
one though i'm really sorry
am i selling that to the duke what
okay convenient let's go
i still don't have a map so
all righty let us continue shall we
so if miranda was the fake mia where's
the real one i doubt she saw any further
use for her
i don't get any of this how did miranda
even know rose exists
a moldy little bird told her maybe we
can figure that out later
focus on the plan i found it
this game is pretty
out for the squad i've located the mega
my seat
so now we can end this mess after all
about damn time let's do it
it just looks like a giant hot and i
don't feel like this is gonna go down
this well i don't think this is gonna
work the way you think it is
not before i end miranda i don't buy it
not taking any more chances
okay if you say something standing by
captain i have eyes on miranda at the
ceremony
keep your distance do not move order
i know it's too late now but we really
should have told ethan the plan
there wasn't time we didn't expect
it so soon even so you
should have told him yeah
this [ __ ] [ __ ] anyway dude i don't
know about that
i just miss lady d honestly
if i'm being real that's that's how i
feel this must be miranda's lab
this is uh very nice
brain functions normal we have a
compliment like that regeneration rate
is incredibly fast subject can heal any
external wound within seconds and grow
her nails into clause and man moments
rapid regeneration also means an
increased body size
hmm ava
okay heisenberg maybe
ah moro hello surprisingly low yikes
dude
it's caused drastic changes to internal
organs transforming them into organs
similar to
fish like gills and a swim bladder
irregular
cell division causing him to transform
into a giant fish the subject is unable
to control
this transformation too many defects
unfit for eva
you talking about unit one or what's up
heisenberg incredibly favorable normal
i would say very functional but okay
electric organs similar to the electric
ray
organs are connected to the subject's
nervous system can therefore pass and
control
electricity through the entire body
allowing control of magnetic fields
which is used to move metal
splendid specimen but still unfit why
what's wrong with him he was perfect he
was a king
among men
donna benviento normal although severe
mental illness physically she is no
different from a regular human habit she
can secrete a signal producing substance
which controls plants infected by me
my seat every time when humans absorb
the pollen
from a particular file she can cause him
to have hallucinations that's kind of
what i
expected however she's mentally
underdeveloped and has divided her keto
among adults in order to control him
from a distance
neat that's batman
this is very awkward asylum if i'm being
honest
who's who's these cool dudes you got
here for me dear miranda my deepest
apologies for not meeting you in person
i would love nothing more than to visit
your quaint village once more however i
am incredibly busy then again i suppose
for such
for an immortal woman such as yourself
you no longer remember this poor
half-dead medical student in the snow
i have always cherished the revelations
i came to 15 years ago when i stayed in
your village i was inspired by your
research oh
interesting
many nights of intellectual talks you
and i shared your conviction differed
from mine you hope to bring back a
single dead person i aimed to change the
world
i had to leave you that's fair
my apologies for reminiscing i actually
have news that i thought might please
you i found
the key to evolution the progenitor a
virus found in africa i plan to start a
company with friends and
umbrella wild just like the symbol in
the cave that we spoke about i'm one
step closer to making my vision a
reality i hope that you will be able to
achieve your goal someday too you taught
me so much and
that i will ever be in your debt oswell
e spencer that's actually very cool
that's cool very neat that's how it all
ties in
no way yes way
that's uh all right that's cute love
that feet
my a vote it's been 100 years since i
lost you to the spanish flu i was so
powerless back then
the timing of all this talk is wild
now i can bring you back to life i had
to test your new vessel's
regenerative abilities i took her apart
and revived her and the giants chalice
all that is left to murder with the mega
my seat
ceremony can find out this is rose after
i lost you i was so stricken with grief
that i wanted into a cave to die
so i wanted to be with you again and
that's when i found it completely by
accident
breaks down and absolves consciousness
of those who have perished yikes
just needed the right vessel which is
rose when i returned to the village i
implanted the villages with mold from
the mega my seat
that way i could control them experiment
on them
oh she created the cat out did i already
know that i don't remember
i was once approached by an organization
who said they would assist me i gave
them some of the mold and your dna but
all they created was another defect
evelyn
then again and not a complete failure i
learned of rose thanks to them and i
knew
she would be the perfect vessel there
was some interference but i was able to
finally verify her suitability now my
research is complete
i've waited too long to see you again
i'm digging all this even if it's not
the greatest way to approach
storytelling
i'm into it um
well i'm gonna have to shoot that lock
off i suppose
that really does look like elise
williams wow
um okay
let's roll
is this real mia show me your hands
i'm bryce this is alpha where is miranda
right now
god there it really is you how long she
been in here for that's my question
i'm glad you saved me why are you here
i was caught in houston experiments
in the flesh what's the situation up
there for how long
nothing we can't handle don't get
distracted stick to the mission i'm
headed to the ceremony site
wait you're not even here you can't
leave me here not even to see if she
needs water or anything
damn it you said that you would keep us
safe
we did everything that you asked we
moved over here everything
and i didn't care so long as we were
together
bad news for you sweetheart can you tell
me
where is my husband both fine both are
fine
they're both doing great actually but um
it's gone you're okay
i couldn't save him but i can save rose
oops
come on it's not safe here after all
after all i mean he's gone he's dead
dude he's dead
[ __ ] he's dead he's super [ __ ] dead
i'm sorry mia but we have to leave she
took his heart out
to destroy this village no you're wrong
i tried to keep this a secret but
you don't understand how special he is
oh ethan can
just fully reach in maybe he's what
she's saying
the bad news is i don't want him to
ah [ __ ] at least i have my magnum mama
back
assumed that they would they would
explain
ethan's absurd ability to regenerate at
some point
yeah it looks cold mate okay
i'm not positive going down the river is
the right way to go but based on them
did i get here framing oh
god i think you'll be okay dude you've
been through much worse than a little
bit of cold
a little frostbite you've got chem flu
you're gonna be fine you're gonna be
fine
may as well be heisenberg if i'm being
perfectly honest
you're so dumb [ __ ] you you're dumb
who do you think you are is this my
daughter
you're dead
dad i don't believe that i mean
there's a lot going on miranda she
no i still have to save rose
wrong it wasn't miranda
you are always dead
what are you saying i can still
see miranda didn't kill you
[Music]
was this harry potter i think it was
weird
no matter how much you got hurt yeah i
know
remember yeah it occurred to me
that resident evil 7 would probably be
related to
ethan being fine years ago
the baker house hi jack
you were murdered by jack
you died there three years ago
that's that's awesome no
way
you shouldn't even be able to walk
around
[Music]
quit messing with my head
zombies
[Music]
right
and how do you get it your whole body
is nothing but mold
again this is what i assumed ever see
your family again
wait why that part i wouldn't have
expected
family wasn't i like this the whole time
because of
what happened in re7
no rose
hi is my daughter mold
save my daughter yes
yes
[Music]
dead
specifically about that is funny evelyn
oh my god
i will save
rose quite a trip
take me back to chris
oh my my my
that is what i expected uh
that uh something happened i just
assumed he got infected
i didn't assume it was his whole body
but here we are
at last he awakes oh my mate
where am i my carriage ethan you were
having a nightmare
duke your battle with heisenberg was a
sight to see
but to think miranda would show herself
how long have i been out not long till
dawn
uh it's until dawn duke i need you for
wait until
i assumed as much and i'm already on the
way how do you feel about her though
like are you she arrived shortly
you guys chill or like she gonna kill
you too
but ethan are you sure of this your body
is
well falling apart
yes foolish of it ass
okay let's roll speaking of foolish
questions
who or what are you
even i can't quite answer that i really
do like him
i think he's wonderful
we're here we're here
i owe you one mr winters
i'm afraid you can't return to your old
world any longer do i still have the
magnum though
are you ready yeah yeah no i'm ready
dude
but as long as i still got that magnum
that's all i'm really worried about
because now i'm gonna use the [ __ ] out
of it
all right am i i gotta go hey
[Music]
it's all looking great it's all looking
great
that way this way
okay i gotta go fight mother miranda
as i would call her as heisenberg
she's a [ __ ] is what he said
but i need to take her down so i can
rescue my
daughter all right
chill out [ __ ] you know
are they gonna drop anything
probably not oh we are one hit killing
people now that's exciting i should
maybe just not even kill him
i gotta keep going yes you do
oh ethan winters
it would have been really fun for him
little evil
beautiful daughter it's all very
connected and i'm impressed
is that you am i too late oh
oh i've missed you
what she looks a bit like a
of valkyrie my
power is leaving me are you just crying
love
could behave it though we haven't
confirmed that ethan
could could be either of them miranda
still don't have that gun
interesting your body certainly isn't
normal
thank you give rose to me
now you will see once i kill you
properly
get her now i don't even see who what
that was
that was chris chris did that did he do
it with my magnum did somebody use my
magnum bullets
my desires will be fulfilled
is mine
what the [ __ ]
well
you fulfilled your purpose mr winters
you disposed of my false children and
awakened the glorious victims
i just want to see what she does you
know now please do not worry
i assure you i'll provide you oh she
takes damage okay
let's just [ __ ] do this then now you
can die
decently
i'm just gonna use all of it just
because
you know don't risk this you understand
the love of a parent
oh my oh that's creepy why the hell
can't you realize
rose is my goddamn kid not yours
i like to think that my mum would do
this for me
said my mum would try to protect me this
hard that was your arm but still
oh no oh my lord and my word
quite strong it granted me this splendid
power you are pretty [ __ ] cold
nuts nah legit you are
this is a cool design
oh what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] with that what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] it is like about grease did these
guys play on a walk
because that's what it feels like after
all everyone
dies i just don't know where you are
love and i need to shoot you right in
your bloody face
all right that's all gone but i feel
like we probably used it well
i don't know if i'm being perfectly
honest
for all time okay
oh my that's a lot what's going on there
[ __ ] hell
jesus okay
okay
it's a cool fight i'm liking it now mr
winters
i think
you can't do that the hell i will
i will take back my daughter
yeah i don't know that you can take her
back isn't she just dead
i don't know if the taking is really
involved in this
is a kind of take situation
i understand your feelings
you might have missed that one
i know i've read it i read you [ __ ]
nerdy papers
you [ __ ] dork a century
i really am digging the law here even if
i feel like i maybe
haven't absorbed it as much as i
probably should have but i am into it
surely you have no need for this now
damn it damn you
hold still i prefer not to if i'm being
perfectly honest
good thing you keep [ __ ] messing with
me
oh [ __ ] in my face now so
she's my daughter dude that's [ __ ] up
damn dawg he's in an air 1.
we finally agreed hey i blocked that i
was walking
i was walking let's not be rude here
okay oh my oh that's my magnum ammo gun
oh no all right what are you gonna do
what are you doing
what's this plan oh gotta get rid of
these things again
wait what really oh yeah
you dodged the last one probably
ah oh my god that was unlucky
all right ethan i've never seen a human
kill this
is she getting faster that's probably a
good sign
but it's bad for me
take that one out boom they
can always touch the last one it's not a
problem
turn into the spider thing again that's
the thing that's [ __ ] me up the most
for sure
might
i'd prefer not to i prefer to persist
oh progress has been made
but i have a knife this is annoying to
ensure i never seen
i think she's probably oh i'm supposed
to block her of course i bloody aim
i should have blocked it oh no it's okay
it's okay i was like i don't need to
it's scripted it is totally scripted
my daughter
dead for a long time love you know what
i've said it before in this play through
you know what could have solved all of
these problems from top to bottom
just a little bit of therapy just a tiny
bit of therapy just an
ounce of therapy and then nobody had to
go through any of this
from the beginning every game wouldn't
have even happened
no umbrella
all right are you ever me are you my
daughter did i have sex with miranda
like
what who
am i alive am i mold it's all right
it's all right
oh no
my hands have been through a lot of [ __ ]
dude they really have
i think you should maybe put the baby
down because you could crumble
you could kill this baby after all that
ethan
ethan ethan
chris very invested come on ethan come
on ethan wake up
oh no chris ethan
he did it it's finished i think we've
finished each
other ethan
nice we gotta move killing miranda
probably
kills all of the mold is the suggestion
here
so ethan is going to die no matter what
it's a well-animated baby
do i have to fight that as well
keep moving ethan there's a bum in that
thing that'll blow this whole village
sky high
oh great hey look at me when i hit this
trigger we can't be anywhere
near it i don't think he's gonna look
interesting
let me just wait for you she's alive you
hear me
alive oh man
i'm so sorry i love you
bros safe hey hey hey
don't worry about it just take the baby
and go he's like he's like moldy dust
and you tell yourself now come on it's
not that much further
classic alpha chad with a baby it's like
cable
watch over teach her to be strong dude
all right
just to make sure they really cut him
off i wonder if
goodbye rosemary
are they gonna bring him back in some
other game as some sort of mold monster
vote
makes you think
i wish this were playable
make me pull the trigger please i yearn
for these halo reach moments
please make me do it make it interactive
i would like to press the button i
didn't i'll pretend that i did
rose
go go take us up now
wait where's ethan quite dead again
didn't he already tell him did mia ever
have the momentum
we have to get clear no i ate dinner in
the middle of
when i died in the boss fight and
restarting it not before you tell me
where ethan
don't okay no she knew he was dead
but she went he's special tell me
what's going on where
that's your man's
sorry about that
what was that at least that well where i
didn't get that shotgun emma blew up
where is he
chris what have you done
he's gone that was his choice oh oh
alpha chad that's right
look at you go don't shout it here and
if it isn't just one
escape
i'm sorry
captain you need to see this
bsaa didn't send soldiers
this is a bio weapon the hell were they
thinking
orders captain pick up the rest of the
squad
plot a course for bsa europe hq
someone's got to pay
hmm
all right we've done it
[Music]
it's this light on the side here have i
done that
is that my doing what's in the game
interesting
um i really enjoyed it
i think this game is really good
obviously played it extremely slowly
because of the need to clear all the
rooms which i'm sure is not the way that
um it's intended to be played so i feel
like the story
was dragged out because i did that i
think i'll probably try to speed run and
see how fast i can finish it i'm
definitely gonna play through it again
had an awesome time it was really fun
thank you everyone for joining me on
this journey
resident evil village um i don't do
youtube playthroughs very often this is
my second one ever
but um maybe i'll do it again
for any triple a survival horror games
because it is my favorite genre okay
and they are few and far between so it
isn't super frequent generally i don't
like doing playthroughs because i prefer
to just play it at my own pace in my own
time
thankfully people don't seem to have
minded me playing this at my own pace
too much
but um yeah
i really enjoyed it it's fun
and i don't really want to skip this
because it's so pretty
and i like whatever this song is but i
also do want to know if there's like
some
post-credits thing
the fish king we did fight the fish king
to do with a horse
that could just be a heisenberg
reference of it being kind of friendly
and then not being friendly at all
potentially
and that's her mother miranda gifts we
gave but more you took
she snarled so more in turn is due in a
blink
the girl was trapped inside a mirror
her parents though had searched all day
and at last
arrived with rampant rage father fought
the witch
while mother's loving touch shattered
the dark enchantment
but the witch was strong and father
yelled save our daughter
so mother bore their child to safety as
the forest was consumed
even now the burnt forest is a grim
reminder of father's sacrifice
to this day any child who stares too
long into the charred
wasteland will be haunted by nightmares
of getting lost
while picking berries
very good
i'll do it
do you think the little boy will be able
to touch the moon
nobody can touch the moon is too far
away wait what if he has a rocket ship
uh okay then you can touch it but it'd
be
very very cold
you were being silly
it's rose
hey dad confirmed happy birthday
[Music]
sorry i missed last week i have a lot of
tests coming up
you know how it is
talk to the goddamn devil
duty calls
i love you
that's a sick jacket dude the jacket is
dope
yeah this is gonna be where else
the day of all days rude dude
we have a situation you're needed
evelyn don't you ever
call me that again oh oh it's just a
joke rose
it's pretty [ __ ] up i can show you
things even chris doesn't know i can do
huh so she's probably gonna be our next
protagonist is my guess
stand down interesting i can handle it
she's just a kid
i want you to keep it together rose
you're a lot like him you know
he's a pretty boy to personality if i'm
being honest i know
i don't know that she is already i feel
like there's a bit more going on with
her
so they're gonna be the baas
or whatever but she's gonna be the new
ethan
even though he was never actually made
to work for them
yeah he wasn't
he chose to do the things for his wife
and his
child
i'm expecting a jump scare nope okay all
good